one two three one two
three one two three that's just to
synchronize the audio
from my recording with the the video so
i'm not crazy i i promise i'm not crazy
hello there it is i monster maze
so that was a pretty big presentation uh
we got to see a lot more than i expected
and
i'm very happy i'm a very happy man
you'll have to excuse the
audio quality it's not the best uh i'm
recording in my living room which i
normally don't do i
normally go into my closet where it's
quiet
and also my pc seems like it's going to
take off at any moment
it's i guess just as excited as i am so
just up front i'm not going to do like
an analysis video or anything like that
it's just not my style you have to be
very quick it's very stressful for me
um and also i'm just too much of a
perfectionist when it comes to my
editing which i cannot do if i have to
do it on the fly
right away so i'm going to show some
stream highlights
i was on the stream with commonwealth
realm which was a lot of fun
and we had don with us who doesn't
really speak
japanese but he knows a little bit he
can hear it and
understand what they're talking about so
that was very helpful
god i wish i spoke japanese anyway i'm
gonna just show you the stream
highlights and then
afterwards i'll do just a really quick
like my final thoughts about it and then
we'll wrap it up
because i'm terrible at improvising
yeah okay gameplay
looks good so far oh look at the run
animation
[Music]
oh yeah
still work like they usually would you
just attack enemies until the
big enemy appears
oh flurry oh look at that
it's a small guardian it's so cute
[Music]
no yeah yeah it is
the empire yeah yeah
that's important oh she looks exactly
exactly right
no no no papaya yeah
sorry oh okay
see the baby now it's time for some
action
bomb scalor yeah that's definitely
important
the hat the head on the back is a big
darn giveaway
yeah yeah well plus the fact that
wait is that is it a tower yep yeah
what tower is that the central highwall
tile
tower yeah it is yeah it is because it's
right next to the
hyrule garrison so the baby guardian
activated after
he got the secret slate from when amber
throw that ahead him
yep that is cool the card scenes look so
cool
they look exactly like a birthday
actually even better it is
it means r2d2 yeah hi
it even sounds like r2d2 okay let's get
inside the garrison
i can't wait to play this oh my god
yes but that's what i was saying because
when you when you have somebody early
available to you
it all it always is the case that they
will be the first playable secondary
playable character look at those
ancient uh chica
so i was already expecting input to be
the second playable character now
look at that she's she fights like moss
kosha
which honestly makes total sense that
honestly it makes total sense that she
would be the second playable character
she looks fun though
[Music]
and i don't know if you guys see this
below the the muso attack with the a
button
she had special runes that she can use
temporarily
do you see that next beneath the a yeah
yeah yeah
don't die now okay we're getting the
moose
much more much more cool attack i'm
sorry her moose attack is better than
lynx
i'm just sorry wait she picked up the
the fire rod can't you use it
why does you mean fire rod that would be
cool if you can pick up weapons press l
please oh no no
come back
i'm so happy empire is playable over the
trailer new
he's likely going to be the trailer they
upload afterwards
let's see
[Music]
he's also using
[Music]
okay so empire is kind of our companion
nice
yeah that's really cool
[Music]
yes
[Music]
did you see that yeah oh jeez i'm
getting goosebumps
yes can we watch the trade also
afterwards in english if it's available
bravo
i'm gonna take it from gender supply
so the gameplay looked very good i love
the parts with impa
impact fights like monk moss kosha which
oh my god that's amazing like she uses
all these
ancient like chica techniques and stuff
like that
[Music]
i have no idea what i'm doing but it
doesn't just feel like a third-party
game that
looks a bit like breath of the wild in
terms of art style but no it actually
seems to control a little bit like it as
well the way
link walks the walk cycle everything
matches the little jingles the little
sounds
that you hear looks like there's gonna
be a little bit of room for exploration
at least just
check out what all the towns looked like
when they were still in their prime and
stuff like that
we finally got to see what the baby
guardian does and
he is basically r2d2 which is very
awesome
to be honest i love r2d2 it looks like
they're going to change
some parts of the lore which i'm totally
fine with
i was always under the impression that
the tower
at the great plateau was the only tower
they found but apparently the one at
hyrule garrison
was also activated maybe even before the
one at the great plateau which
uh makes sense i guess
so i was already kind of expecting this
but it looks like
a large portion of the game is going to
take place pre-calamity
like probably at least 50 percent of the
game and i'm totally fine with that
because it's the turning point
of the game it's it's a big deal you
know when kind of get
when gannon when gannon finally rises up
so we have to first get rid of all the
monster
attacks maybe even find the divine
beasts
i don't know and then as soon as ganon
arises that's when it starts to go down
as soon as the guardians start to come
into play
it's gonna be a tough one for for
everyone but especially for the
champions
so yeah that pretty much wraps it up uh
i wasn't really planning on filming
myself but
i thought it would be a little bit like
a nice little extra and not just show
you
uh stream highlights and stuff like that
but uh
i'd like to thank everyone for watching
my videos in general like i've been
having a lot of fun with the heroes path
ones
after that there's tons of other stuff
to come i i still have
plenty of ideas so i will see you
in the next video